dans la petite troupe qui portent
emmanuel macron au pouvoir alexandre des
dunlop dénote pas un fils de pas de
grandes écoles il né en 1991 en
normandie
une enfance dans la zup d'evreux puis
dans le bocage dans les films les
personnages qui préfèrent sont souvent
les gardes du corps
[Musique]
la sphère benalla elle a duré tellement
longtemps que tout cela peut mélanger
dans les têtes et nous on voulait la
l'inscrire dans la durée la raconter
dans la durée et d'ailleurs il ya 2000
épisodes dont on ne se souvient pas et
qui paraissent complètement
invraisemblable l'intérêt de la bd aussi
c'est de faire pénétrer un monde c'est à
dire que vous rentrez tout d'un coup par
la grande porte et non pas par la grille
du coq à l'elysée et vous voyez comment
fonctionne le pouvoir la vente décidée
sa phase bêta et moi moi c'était manuel
macron ce n'est pas ni franchi a cru
gagner moi même qui avons écrit cette
bande dessinée avec les dessins de
julien soler c'était l'idée de raconter
un couple finalement assez classique
dans l'exercice du pouvoir le prince
elle conseillé et puis aussi un moment
du quinquennat de d'emmanuel macron on
se souvient que l est et 2018
il est encore dans une sorte d'état de
grâce et puis d'un coup patatras
arrive la ferme et dallas
[Musique]
cette histoire elle est assez
rocambolesques et je pense que c'est
pour cette raison qu'à la fois le seuil
de la redessiner ont pensé à un format
bd d'ailleurs les dessins de julien
soleil sont intéressants parce qu'il
montre bien aussi les mimiques le drame
qui passent sur les visages l'anxiété la
panique aussi un moment certaines nuits
à l'elysée ça veut pas dire que cette
affaire soit légère ou qu'elle ne soit
pas grave a eu des conséquences assez
dramatique par exemple sur la popularité
des manuels macron les sondages se sont
écroulés à l'été 2010 8 mais aussi parce
que elle est restée dans les esprits
[Musique]
j'avais lu la bd de fabrice arfi sur
kadhafi et le financement de la campagne
de nicolas sarkozy
c'est une affaire très complexe cette
affaire là beaucoup plus complexe que la
sphère bva qui au fond est assez simple
on a un personnage principal un
président de la république
une bagarre le premier mais tout ça est
finalement très visuel les relations
entre avec 100 bédard à emmanuel macron
elle raconte évidemment presque plus
emmanuel maintenant qu'avec sont bénins
mais elle raconte aussi de manière plus
générale ce lien qu'entretiennent les
puissants avec des conseillers qui
peuvent leur rapporter ce qui se passe à
paris au château et ça ça a toujours
existé ça existait sous françois
mitterrand ça existait sous jacques
chirac ça existait sous françois
hollande et c'est toujours intéressant à
raconter
[Musique]